gerald 15s bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
parle de 30 à 14 40 % de mortalité de
patients en réanimation un chiffre
largement au dessus de ce qu'a annoncé
le gouvernement comment l'expliquez vous
c'est surtout les chiffres annoncés par
le gouvernement est largement inférieur
à la réalité mais en fait c'est pas un
manque de transparence ou invention sur
les chiffres en fait on parle de deux
choses différentes le chiffre a été
annoncé par le directeur général de la
santé tous les jours c'est un chiffre à
l'instant t c'est une photographie de la
mortalité mais la mortalité individuel
d'impatience et un parcours de soins et
cette mortalité elle peut être différée
elle peut être à 28 jours elle est
retardée par rapport à une entrée en
réanimation évidemment les gens ne
rentrent pas et ne meurt pas tout de
suite en réanimation il meurt au bout de
plusieurs jours donc on a d'un côté une
photographie à un instant t de jérôme
salomon un directeur général de la santé
et de l'autre on a le parcours des
patients elle reflet la mortalité qui ne
peut ce décompte et qu'a posteriori et
entre nous on n'a jamais vu des services
de réanimation avec uniquement
malheureusement 10 % de mortalité dans
la mortalité dans ce service là et y est
beaucoup plus importante parce que ce
sont les plus et patients les plus
graves les plus lourds de l'hôpital et
même du système de soins qui se
retrouvent en réanimation donc nous on
n'est pas du tout étonné un de ces 30 à
40%
c'est une mortalité élevée importante
qui augmente avec l'âge aussi mais elle
n'a rien d'exceptionnel malheureusement
dans un service de réanimation
elle était juste tout simplement mal
comprises ou ou sous-estimé dans la
communication de jérôme salomon tous les
soirs mais parce que encore une fois
c'était la photo à l'instant t
est ce que cette mortalité élevé traduit
les limites de capacité des services de
réanimation français non je ne pense pas
même si le retard en fait quand vous
êtes en réanimation et j'allais dire
vous avez de la chance c'est à dire que
tous les moyens vont vous être donnée
parce que vous êtes arrivé en
réanimation
là où il y aura un prennent de capacités
des structures sanitaires c'est le fait
de ne pas arriver en réanimation une
fois que vous êtes en réanimation tous
les soins vous sont donnés tout l'enjeu
en particulier éthique c est ce que tout
le monde a eu les soins adaptés à son
état
et ça c'est une vraie question on avait
vu en italie ce cessez choix dramatique
par les médecins de en fonction de la
de d'admission en réanimation il ya
probablement eu en france aussi des
critères de réanimation d'entrée en
réanimation au cur été plus sévère que
d'habitude parce que l'attention se les
services de réanimation faisait qu' il
fallait priori il est aussi je parle pas
de tri mais vraiment de priorisation ce
qui est le boulot du réalisateur et même
de l'urgentiste tous les jours mais là
peut-être que les plus drastiques que
d'habitude
et puis je pense que malheureusement il
ya eu des choix faits en amont en amont
de l'hôpital en particulier dans les
ehpad dans les maisons de retraite ou
des gens n'ont pas été proposés à
l'hôpital à tort en disant l'hôpital est
saturé ce qui était d'ailleurs assez fou
les rênes il va sur était saturé mais
pas l'hôpital et ces patients là on
aurait pu bénéficier je pense donc là il
faudra à postériori se poser ces
questions éthiques dans la même de
responsabilité pour essayer de faire un
peu le bilan
alors ces dernières 24 heures il ya eu
un léger rebond des décès en france les
services de réanimation elle accueille
moins de malades
est ce que le plan de déconfinement qui
va être annoncé par edouard philippe cet
après midi va tenir la route en tout cas
ce que la date du 11 mai et crédible à
vos yeux pour voilà comment ça des
confiner le pays
c'est une balance bénéfices risques un
peu comme en médecine quand vous
prescrive un médicament fauqué plus de
bénéfices que de risques là le
confinement il a eu des bénéfices
on a figé le virus maintenant il
comporte probablement plus de risque et
notamment économiques que sociaux
psychologiques ou tout ce que vous
voulez donc on voit bien que on ne peut
pas maintenir ce confinement donc ce
qu'il faut c'est l'organiser mais avec
le plus de garanties possibles et
organisé cette sortie de confinement les
masques les tests etc
voilà où je suis très étonné pour
rebondir sur le sujet des réanimations
et des services hospitaliers sert qu'une
des conditions de réussite est une des
conditions d'accélération du
déconfinement dans de bonnes conditions
ça serait d'augmenter des capacités
hospitalières parce que vous voyez bien
que plus vous allez avoir de la marge de
sécurité dans les services de
réanimation dans des services non
qu'ovide par exemple ou des services qu
vide parce qu'il faut bien imaginer que
l'hôpital doit redémarrer aussi
l'hôpital a tenu parce qu on a confiné
tout le monde et parce qu'on a arrêté
toutes les autres activités
donc tout ça il faut les redémarrer et
je suis assez étonné que ce cette partie
sur les capacités
hospitalier à l'augmentation
éventuellement delhi pour avoir des
services ou des hôpitaux dédié aux
copies de façon à des confiné en plus de
sécurité
et bien ne soit pas du tout abordé on
aborde le déconfinement je me sous
l'angle distance physique sous l'angle
avoir des masques avoir des tests mais
la casse sanitaire qu'il y aura et en
aura forcément puisque le virus var
circuler avec le pays qui va redémarrer
eh bien il faut qu'on soit capable de
l'absorber et ça ça va devenir beaucoup
plus compliqué quand on va à voir tous
les patients qui ont eu un retard de
soins et qu'il faut que reprendre qu'il
faut réopéré et c est passée en tenant
des cancers qui ont des infarctus et c
est donc cet angle des capacités
hospitalières me semble extrêmement
important et stratégique pour pouvoir
réussir ce déconfinement il est très peu
abordée cherhal 15 et merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
urgentiste et chroniqueur santé